president Trump's former chief
strategist is bashing fellow Republicans
to defend Roy warm Steve Bannon joined
the GOP Senate candidate in Alabama last
night telling a rally that sexual
misconduct allegations against Mort were
a setup that's his words at least nine
women accused more of wrongdoing Manuel
Bojorquez is in Fairhope Alabama the
scene of the rally Manuel good morning
good morning that special Senate
election here is less than a week away
Roy Moore and his opponent Doug Jones
held perhaps their most combative
rallies to date yesterday Jones says
it's a referendum on human decency Moore
supporter Steve Bannon says it's a
referendum on Washington elites with
flake and Romney and McConnell and the
whole crap this is the scam they don't
mind giving up a seat to a Democrat
Steve Bannon swung at several so-called
establishment Republicans Tuesday
particularly Mitt Romney who tweeted no
vote is worth losing their honor and
integrity while we're on the subject of
Vietnam and honor and integrity you
avoided service brother you went to
France to be a missionary what guys were
dying in rice paddies in Vietnam do not
talk to me about honor and integrity
judge Roy Moore followed Bannon on stage
we're gonna see if the people of Alabama
will support the president its agenda at
a luncheon with Republican senators
President Trump on Tuesday doubled down
on his support for more I think he's
gonna do very well we don't want to have
a liberal Democrat seated next to mr.
Trump was one of his fiercest Republican
critics Arizona Senator Jeff Flake I
have a very different view of joy more
and what that does to the party in
protest flake tweeted this photo of his
$100 donation to Moores opponent
Democrat Doug Jones Roy Moore has never
ever served our state with honor
while trailing more in recent polls
Jones is waging an increasingly
aggressive campaign a damn sure believe
that I have done my part
to ensure that men who hurt little girls
should go to jail
and not the United States Senate in
recent weeks Jones has raised more than
10 million dollars that's about five
times as much as Roy Moore Gayle all
right thank you very much man well